so I thought we'd talk about something a
little bit different today I you know
I've been talking a lot about politics
and I hate politics because I find
politics extremely boring and I'll bore
myself to death if I if I continue with
it
for too long so a little bit of a
different discussion I was having this
debate on Twitter over the past day and
a half this debate about the issue of of
young Earth Creationism
and of course Twitter is the perfect
forum for theological and scientific
debate actually it's it's a terrible
forum for that sort of discussion or any
kind of discussion so I thought maybe
we'd move it into a more move the
discussion into a slightly more fruitful
venue although I have been told I'm that
I'm alienating and man fat to lose half
my audience with my opinion on this
topic so maybe I should just drop it
that's what I've been told but I'm not
very good at dropping things number one
and I like to try to hold people and
myself to a higher standard than that we
should be able to discuss an important
and interesting issue without getting
angry without getting offended or losing
respect for each other and all this kind
of thing and I know that I need to work
on that first and foremost because in
our debates on Twitter about this I know
that I got a bit heated and angry at
points and I regret that I regret it
because it detracts from the topic which
is an interesting and important one but
sometimes I let my my passion run away
with me as I'm sure you've noticed
something I need to work on so let me
say at the outset that good and faithful
Christians reside on either end of this
debate there's no reason for it to be a
source of division within Christians
within within the church within
Christianity but there is reason for it
to be a source of discussion and though
I don't question the sincerity or the
faithfulness of six-day creationist
folks I do think that their view when it
is preached and argued for can
inadvertently do some harm not not
inadvertently it's not like they're
trying to hurt anybody of course but I
do think it can it can put obstacles in
the way especially for for non
leavers and I'll get to that I'll
explain why but first I want to explain
why I'm not a six-day creationist and
and then I'll talk about why that you
know why the six-day creationist view is
in my in my opinion counterproductive so
there's a lot to get to we'll proceed
alright first of all just setting the
stage here when somebody asks me and I
get that I get this question kind of
frequently someone says do you take the
whole Bible literally right I always
find that to be a confusing question do
you take the Bible literally it's a very
confusing question I think that the
literal versus non literal debate is
it's a false dichotomy it's kind of its
kind of a miscommunication really
between the between the two sides much
like I would say the faith versus works
debate is isn't really a debate it's
it's a false dichotomy it's a
miscommunication that's been going on
for 500 years because nobody thinks that
you can earn your way to heaven just by
doing certain things and faith doesn't
matter at all nobody thinks that no
Church that I'm aware of teaches that
that's not I don't think that's really a
belief that almost anyone holds everyone
knows that you have to have faith the
question is not whether you must have
faith everyone agrees yes all Christians
agree yes anyway but the question is
what is faith and how is it expressed is
faith just a feeling an intellectual
assent is that all faith is or is it
something that you feel think do and
live you know that's really the
fundamental question there
and as for literalism nobody takes the
whole Bible literally okay nobody does
we all agreed that there are parts of
the Bible that cannot be taken literally
we all agree for example that the
parables that Jesus's parables are
parables their stories Jesus did not
mean for us to assume that the prodigal
son is a real historical person so that
is non literal obviously he was telling
a story to illustrate a point Jesus
speaks non literally quite a lot for
example
he calls himself the door but we know
he's not a literal door right he this is
a speaking in a spiritual sense he is
the door to eternal life
that's a metaphor and I tell you you are
Peter on this rock I will build my
church and the gates of Hell shall not
prevail against it
is Peter an actual rock no he's not he's
Jesus literally building a physical
church with bricks and wood and things
no as far as we know he never built a
church is there a literal gate leading
into hell probably not it's a
non-physical place so I don't know what
a physical barrier what could a physical
barrier would do in a non-physical place
so so this is non literal language you
get the idea I think by the way it is
kind of instructive and interesting that
God in the New Testament uses non
literal language so often you know he
uses stories to make his point and he
uses metaphors so often in the New
Testament so we have to ask ourselves
did he just start doing that in the New
Testament or is it possible that he did
it in the Old Testament too well even in
the Old Testament there's agreement that
some of it is non literal even even the
so called biblical literalists would
agree that the Psalms for instance are
not literal yes the Psalms literally
exist but their poetry their hymns it
makes no sense to say that you take
poetry and hymns literally you may as
well say say that you take you may as
well ask me well do you take Beethoven's
fifth symphony literally but what does
that mean I take Beethoven literally I
think he literally existed but a
symphony is not a thing to be taken
literally it is outside of the literal
non-literal debate the Song of Solomon
set me as a seal on your arm for Stern
as death is love again not literal we're
not talking about self-mutilation here
and carving someone's name into your arm
that's not what we're talking about back
to the New Testament revelation I don't
think very many people believe that
revelation gives us an exact literal
account of what Willis transpire at the
end of the world there probably
aren't going to be actual horses and
lampstands coming out of the sky and so
forth this language is heavily
metaphorical I think we all basically
agree with that the point is that when
you're reading the Bible which is
comprised of dozens of books written by
dozens of different office authors over
hundreds of years what you have to do is
you have to first determine what genre
each of the books belong to because they
don't all belong in the same genre there
are many different genres in the Bible
there's it's not one genre the Psalms
are not the same genre as the Gospels
the Gospels what's the genre of Gospels
well that's easy enough
biography right Paul's letters are in
the epistles onra which again is a genre
that doesn't really belong in the
literal verse non-literal discussion st.
Paul says many things literally of
course but he also uses metaphor simile
analogy and so on so then we get to
Genesis now again we've already
established that the Bible contains what
we might call non-literal genres
everyone agrees on that and it also
contains literal genres so such such as
the Gospels with for instance so now we
ask is what genre is is is genesis is it
meant to be read is it is it is it a
science of textblock is it meant to be
read as a precise scientific account of
the origins of the universe is that why
Genesis is there is that what God wants
us to take from it does he want us to
study it like we study a science book of
course he wants us to study it but is it
is it to be studied as a science
textbook if you if you were to isolate
Genesis and put it in a section of the
bookstore by itself would it be in the
science section do you think that
Genesis should or can be used as a
reference for serious geological and
cosmological study could a theoretical
physicist kind of check his work by
consulting the Bible historian who wants
to who wants to know about Jesus will
certainly consult the Gospels the
Gospels and the epistles are
essentially the only first-hand accounts
that he can consult so the Gospels are
historical documents but a cosmologists
who's trying to figure out what's going
on with the universe will probably not
look at the creation story in Genesis
because Genesis is not a cosmological
resource it is a theological resource
it's not going to be in the science
section it belongs in the theology
section is a theological work not a
scientific one which isn't to say that
it's false it is still 100% true it is
still the Word of God but the truth that
it contains is a transcendent timeless
truth so it's true but you have to know
how to read it ok now there are many
Christians who insist that Genesis
describes a literal six-day creation ok
and literal six-day creation as in a a
literal 24-hour day you know 6 days in a
week and they say cite as their proof
the fact that it says day that's that's
pretty much it that's that's the entire
that's all the evidence is the word day
and the word day is in there the word
the word day does exist and the word day
is true no one is saying or at least I'm
not saying that the word day is a
falsehood or that it's a lie it's not
but are we talking about a 24-hour earth
day or some sort of other kind of day
now I think the latter I don't take it
as a 24-hour day and so I'm agreeing
with many of the great doctors and
Fathers of the Church Justin Martyr
clement of alexandria agustin many of
the great current apologists and
theologians like you know William Lane
Craig and John Lennox Bishop Baron along
with by the way of my favorite 19th and
20th century apologists like CS Lewis
and John Henry Newman none of them were
or are avowed 6-day creationists
and and a great many of the great
teachers and thinkers of Christianity
have from the beginning held that
Genesis is not entirely literal which is
which is really I think interesting that
you had so many Christians who came to
this conclusion before there was modern
science - in my view basically proof
that it was not a 24 hour six 24-hour
periods so I agree with all them and I
feel very safe in their company and I'll
explain why first let's look at what
happens on day four let's start with day
four I mean jump ahead for a minute and
we'll circle back but day four then and
God said let lights appear in the sky to
separate day from night and to show the
time when days years and religious
festivals begin they will shine in the
sky to give light to the earth and it
was done so God made the two larger
lights the Sun to rule over the day and
the moon to rule over the night he also
made the Stars he placed the lights in
the sky to shine on the earth to rule
over the day and night and to separate
light from darkness and God was pleased
with what he saw evening passed and
morning came that was the fourth day so
the Sun just came on to the scene the
Sun was just created on day four all the
stars trillions and trillions of stars
all made on day four yet God said let
there be light on day one he said let
there be light before there was any
source of physical light so the light of
day one is not a physical light it is
not a light in the way that we think of
it there is no Sun there are no stars
there there is no moon there is there
isn't a formed earth yet the earth is
formless on day one it is a form it is
formless and void we're told on day one
does it make sense to assume that we're
talking about a 24-hour earth day when
the earth is a formless void and there
is no Sun why should we think that
what's the reason imagine yourself
standing or or floating I guess in the
midst of a shapeless formless mass with
no Sun or moon or star
the sky what is a day in that context I
I mean it could be a 24 hours
period I guess but there's no reason at
all to assume that let's think about
this let's let's define our terms what
is a day in our current context what
does day mean if we're talking about a
so called literal day if we're referring
to you know the calendar when we say day
well what we mean is a day a day is when
the earth as it orbits the Sun makes one
full rotation on its axis thus causing
the Sun - from our perspective rise and
set but the Bible talks about days
before there is a rotating earth before
there really is an earth at all at least
a an earth of any of discernible shape
and before there's a Sun for the earth
to rotate around
thus we can already say rather
definitively I think that we're not
talking about an earth day we're talking
about a twenty we're not talking about a
24-hour day because such a thing does
not yet exist now you know I don't even
think we don't even need to get into the
translation discussion if you look at
the word in the Hebrew word for day does
it have to mean 24 hours or could it be
referring to a broader kind of passage
of time in English the word day means
either a 24-hour period corresponding
with the rotation of the earth that's
one definition or a day means an age a
period of time can the can day be
understood in Hebrew in the same sort of
way and the answer is yes it can be it
the the word day in Hebrew can mean
several different things there are those
who say that he that the Hebrew word for
day as it's used in Genesis cannot ever
mean anything but a 24-hour day that is
simply false that is not true and this
is one of my problems you know with some
of the young earth creationist is that
they look at this text that people have
been studying for thousands of years
and it's very dense and in fact very
complex and they say no I know it
exactly what it means and I know exactly
what it means there's zero chance that
I'm wrong
and they'll say no they can't mean
anything but that and it's just not true
what they're saying is simply untrue it
can mean many different things in
English you know if I say back in my day
or in the days of old I don't mean a
24-hour period I mean a chunk of time in
fact in Genesis itself day is used in at
least three different ways in Genesis he
named the light day in the darkness
night okay that's one meaning of day
first day second day that's another
meaning of day and then it says you are
free to eat from the tree in the garden
but you must not eat from the tree of
knowledge of good and evil for on the
day you eat from it you will certainly
die well Adam lived were told for 900
years he didn't die on the day that he
ate it yes he died spiritually but
physical death also came from the fall
so it would seem that died in that verse
has two meanings which would mean that
day probably has multiple meanings as
well so you've got you've got day used
in multiple different ways within
genesis Regenesis to see that so we we
already know that you cannot approach
Genesis with only one definition of day
in mind the text does not support it
won't allow for it most crucially though
we know from the text itself that a day
cannot mean the earth spinning on its
axis as it orbits the Sun because the
day is the D word day is being used here
completely apart from the Sun and the
earth and rotations and everything that
physically defines a day the light on
the first day is obviously something
transcendent it is not if it is not a
light from a physical source it is
something timeless it's not physical
there is there is not yet any source any
physical source of light
so if the light is different and
transcendent that means the evening and
morning it refers to must be different
and transcendent as well which means the
word day must be as well we're dealing
with a different sort of light a
different sort of morning therefore and
a different sort of day therefore the
thing that makes physical earth-days
24-hour days that thing has not yet been
formed Agustin thought that the light
and darkness on the first day describes
the angels and demons as the light is
separate from the dark just as the
rebellious angels are separated from the
loyal ones that's how he interpreted
that I'm not sure if that's true but the
point is that a group that many great
minds in the church from the beginning
have recognized that we're dealing with
something bigger deeper vaster than
literal days and nights you know young
earth creationists like to say that or
or think that there that there's is the
traditional view but in the most
orthodox view but it's not necessarily
it is a traditional view but it is not
the traditional view the early church
fathers and doctors of the church had
diverse views on this topic and I'm okay
with diverse views I think that's great
it seems to me the 6-day creationist to
insist that there can be no diversity
diversity at all and he is absolutely
right and everyone else is wrong that
seems what it it seems to be you know
the way that the young earth creationist
approaches it there's also a bit of a
reductionist thing going on here because
because I've heard it said many times
well Genesis is clear the text says what
it says how could you be confused it's
it's very straightforward that's what
I've been told
really Genesis is clear it's
straightforward in the beginning God
created the heavens on the earth now the
earth was formless and empty darkness
was over the surface of the deep and the
Spirit of God was hovering over the
waters
that's totally clear to you you have no
confusion about that at all well well
then you are I mean you're way smarter
than me and I think you're smarter than
almost every human who has ever existed
on the planet because because I
people have been debating and talking
and analyzing just those lines alone for
set for millennia because it's very hard
to understand what even that means and
we're not gorget we're not even past the
first two sentences yet I mean if you
understand well explain to me what
explain to me what a formless earth
looks like and how it has water on it
and what it means for the Spirit of God
to hover over it if you say that it's
totally clear-cut clear-cut plain as day
nothing metaphorical happening here at
all
well then draw me a picture of what a
waterlogged formless mass of Earth
suspended in a starless sunless moonless
void looks like can you tell me that
picture I mean I don't think you can
because we're dealing with something
that is actually not simple at all
you could spend your whole life studying
just the first two sentences also by the
way God rested what does that mean do
you know what that means I don't really
know what that means do you know what it
means for an eternal changeless
spaceless timeless God to rest I don't
dispute the truth of the passage but I'm
saying that I don't really know what it
means I can't wrap my puny-minded it I
don't think you can either we're dealing
here with things that are beyond us
which is yet another reason not to
insist upon particular time measurements
and it's another reason not to be so
afraid of the idea that there may be
some metaphor here because when God is
trying to communicate something to us
that is beyond our grasp he has to use
metaphor because it's the only thing we
can understand and so when it comes to
Genesis there are clearly things
happening here that are beyond our grasp
also keep something else in mind just to
reiterate a day does not mean 24 hours
that is not the definition of a day so
when someone says oh I'm a literalist I
take it literally well that's not the
literal definition if you're insisting
that that day must mean 24 hours you are
not a literalist
you
actually putting a non-literal
definition into the text a day is not 24
hours necessarily that is not the
definition of day a day on earth right
now is 24 hours because that's how long
it takes now for the earth to rotate on
its axis a day on Pluto is like 130
hours on some planets in the solar
system a day is thousands of hours long
day the word day depends very much on
what space rock you happen to be
standing on and when you happen to be
standing on it so let me ask you was the
formless earth suspended in a void
without a Sun spinning on an axis did it
have an axis and if it was spinning how
fast was it spinning the answer of
course is you have no idea not the
faintest clue which means you have not
the faintest clue how long a day was in
that context if you're saying it must
have been a day as we think of it then
what you're saying the definition of day
is rotating on an axis which means that
you are saying that you know 100% that a
formless shapeless earth suspended in a
void with a transcendent non-physical
spiritual light shining upon it must
have absolutely been it had been
spinning and taken twenty-four hours to
complete its rotation I just don't know
how anyone could ever say that and it to
me it's such an odd thing to insist upon
absolutely so we have no reason at all
to assume that it was twenty-four hours
but we do have very many good reasons I
think to assume that it wasn't and we'll
get to those in a minute
remember scripture says that a day for
man is like a thousand years for God so
really if you're a true literal list it
would seem to me that you have to say
that the earth was made in 6,000 years
not six days
if you're taking it literally if you're
taking you the whole book literally
which no one does as I said but if you
are if you claim to be then you would
have to take that verse into account but
of course like a thousand years is not
an exact math equation it is not a rate
of exchange it's just a it's
metaphorical language meant to convey
the point that when God says he did
something in a day
it doesn't mean a day the way we think
of it a day for him is not a day for us
by the way isaiah 40:22 he sits
enthroned above the circle of the earth
and its people are like grasshoppers he
stretches out the heavens like a canopy
and spreads them out like a tent to live
in here we are told that the earth is a
circle circles are flat
we're told that God is above it
enthroned so again must we take this as
literal must we believe that NASA is
lying to us and that actually God is up
literally in the sky hanging out next to
the satellite must we believe that the
earth that the earth is flat like people
used to believe the Bible also speaks
frequently of the ends of the earth
that's one of the reasons the people
that used to believe in the Flat Earth
they would point to those verses and
they would say ends of the earth
apparently the earth has an end but a
sphere has no end so we don't take it
literally Psalm 104 he set the earth on
its foundation it can never be moved
must we take this literally and believe
that the earth does not move science
tells us that the earth is hurdling
through space and incomprehensible
speeds it's constantly moving rotating
spinning orbiting even the ground itself
the plates are moving everything is
moving everything and on earth is
constantly in motion must we deny all of
that science for the sake of taking it
literally by the way early Christians
and Jews did take this literally that's
part of the reason why Copernicus and
Galileo got themselves into trouble
because the Bible says absolutely that
the earth doesn't move and so when
people when when up start
astronomers started coming along and
saying the earth is moving they said
that can't be the Bible says it doesn't
complain as de it says it does not move
and that's why many Christians at the
time rejected and denounced in the
harshest terms any suggestion that the
earth moves they did so on the basis of
their interpretation of Scripture which
they insisted should not change one bit
to accommodate scientific fact John
Calvin and Martin Luther were were were
two of the most vocal critics of the
idea of a of a spitting of a moving
earth
John Calvin called it deranged and
monstrous he said it was a deranged
monstrous lie
well eventually Christians realized that
their interpretation of these verses had
to be wrong because the scientific facts
are indisputable the earth is moving it
cannot be disputed so we must take those
verses metaphorically if we can take
those metaphorically why can't we take
de metaphorically one other point here
in the story of creation every day
begins with and God said God speaks at
the beginning of the day and that's how
we mark each day but read the opening of
Genesis again the opening is in the
beginning God created the heavens on the
earth now the earth was formless and
empty darkness over the surface of water
and God said let there be light many
theologians have looked at this over the
years and and they've pointed out that
the first two lines don't take place on
the first day the first day begins with
and God said so what we're being told
here according to this interpretation
which I think is a good one is that God
created the heavens and the earth at
some point in the beginning whenever
that was and we aren't told wind because
it doesn't doesn't matter at all really
at least it has no bearing on the point
the Bible is trying to make
and so it was made at some point in the
beginning and then sometime later maybe
billions of years the first day began
and there was light etc it doesn't say
on the first day God created the heavens
on the earth
it says in the beginning and then
there's a first day so with all these
points in mind you hopefully see why I
think the Bible does not require us to
believe in in a in a young Earth
Creationism you can believe it you can
draw that conclusion theologically but
you don't have to it's not required
there's a reason why faithful Christians
for 2,000 years have arrived at
different conclusions on Genesis it's
not a simple text is it is not easy to
understand it's quite dense quite
mysterious and theologically you can
justify multiple interpretations but if
we're interested in getting some idea as
to how these things physically happened
and win if we want to you know if that's
what we're trying to figure out then I
think we look at the science and then
when we look at the science certain
interpretations of Genesis become
significantly less tenable the real
point of the Bible is about the Bible is
all about why why we're here we're here
to love and serve God science has
nothing to say about that one way or
another we can't cross-reference that
with science but when it comes to our
interpretations of the hell and the
wind's well then things like archeology
cosmology physics all of that becomes
useful science tells us that the earth
is around four billion years old or I'm
sorry the yeah the earth is four billion
around four billion in the universe is
around fourteen billion years old in
order to defend the 6-day creationist
view we must essentially reject the
fields of modern astronomy cosmology
geology and biology we must declare that
all but a very tiny fraction of experts
in
fields are deluded fools we must
basically wage an all-out war on modern
science because it stands so explicitly
and starkly against young Earth
Creationism I'll say this you will be
very hard-pressed to find a legitimate
geologist or cosmologists or physicist
or astronomer who believes based on his
studies that the earth and the universe
are ten thousand years old maybe you'll
find a few who believe who hold that
belief in spite of their studies
maybe you'll maybe you'll you know maybe
you'll find a few here and there who
will say something like yeah I mean you
could interpret the science in a way
that kind of comports with young Earth
Creationism I mean you're gonna be very
hard-pressed to find any scientist who
will even say that much but there are a
few I mean young earth creationists
they'll they have a few scientific names
they'll try it out and they'll say well
this person that person that you know
it's a few but even those people if you
listen to what they're saying they're
not claiming that they can prove this
just by looking at the evidence ient if
evidence what they're starting with
Genesis and their interpretation of it
and then trying to make the science fit
and that's that's just that's not how
you do science that's not real science
now I fully admit that I'm neither a
cosmologists or a geologist so I must
decide whether I will believe the near
unanimous consensus in those fields or
if I will come to the conclusion that
they're all a bunch of godless liars and
lunatics because certain Christians
insist that the word day in Genesis can
only mean 24 hours and nothing else I
must ask myself what's more likely that
the entire fields of cosmology astronomy
and geology are wrong illegitimate and
falsified or that young earth
creationists are simply misinterpreting
the text what's the more plausible
explanation that modern science is
completely wrong or that young earth
creation
are misinterpreting it and it isn't just
those scientific fields that young
earthers need to disqualify there are
many others that we basically are
disqualified paleontology most every
paleontologists in the world will tell
you that dinosaurs existed and they died
off 60 million years ago but young
earthers based on one word in the Bible
that they have interpreted in one
particular way will say to
paleontologists nope you're all wrong
all of your work is wrong your life's
work is wrong everything you think is
wrong it's everything you've studied
it's all wrong wrong wrong wrong wrong
because I believe that the word day in
Genesis can only mean 24 hours I just
you know it doesn't make any sense so
you we have to discard and and then and
then you know young earth is what must
must also say that well diner they say
dinosaurs never existed and it's all a
big sham I've heard I've had some young
earthers tell me that God put dinosaur
bones in the earth to test our faith
it's all a prank that he's playing on us
or that um that there were Tyrannosaurus
rexes and brontosauruses and Triceratops
and Stegosaurus is on Noah's Ark somehow
they all fit on there and didn't and
they also didn't eat everybody and then
once they got off the ark they all died
in some mass extinction event that only
affected the dinosaurs and then all of
their bones somehow sifted in and sunk
lower in the ground than any other bones
and they fossilized so as to take on the
appearance of age I mean it's just
you've got to run through all of these
massive loops and you've got to do these
twirls and handstands and everything to
make this work when you don't need to
archaeology is another field of study
that young earthers would have to
basically disqualify archaeologists have
dug up many ancient artifacts sculptures
and so forth that are clearly made by
humans and are clear
the older than 10,000 years
significantly older like 30 40 50
thousand years there are for example
many of what are called Venus sculptures
sculptures of large women with
exaggerated features that seem to
indicate some kind of fertility worship
by ancient people some of these ninis
sculptures are significantly older than
10,000 years you will not find a
legitimate archaeologist who will look
at every prehistoric artifact and
declare based on his study of those
artifacts that none of them were made
before 10,000 years you will not find
one who can say that
so archeology has to be bunk as well on
the young earth view physics Albert
Einstein one of the most brilliant minds
ever to exist on earth believed that the
universe was billions of years old but
young earthers I mean they basically
tell us that we have to treat Ken Ham as
a greater authority on the subject and
Einstein and I just can't do that
mathematics must also be discarded on
the young earth view because it is
through mathematical equations that we
measure cosmic distance and age and so
Jung earthers are saying that even
mathematics we can't trust nothing can
be trusted in fact we know that if
you're looking at a star and the star is
however many light-years away you're
looking that many years into the past
because it took that many years for the
light to reach here and this is a huge
problem for young earthers it may
actually be the biggest problem of all I
think it's the thing above everything
else that settles the question and it's
an insurmountable problem I think for
young earthers any stars that we have
located which are over 10,000
light-years from us would seem to prove
beyond a shadow of a doubt that the
universe is older than 10,000 years
otherwise we wouldn't be able to see
them because the light wouldn't have
gotten to us yet you see the Hubble
Space Telescope recently located a star
nine billion light-years away which is
to say that it looked nine bill
years into the past which is incredible
you know they say we can't look into the
past we don't have a time machine we do
and go outside at night and look up in
the sky you're in a time machine you're
looking at the past all of those stars
you're looking at what the Stars looked
like thousands or millions of years ago
so I think that's a rather
insurmountable problem here's the thing
to prove young Earth Creationism you
need to do a whole lot more than just
quibble with the methodology of some of
these disciplines you need to do more
than say well maybe carbon dating is
inaccurate you certainly need to do more
than show me a couple of vague ambiguous
stains on a cave wall somewhere that you
say must be paintings of dinosaurs and
therefore must on their own upend the
entire fossil record no that's not
nearly enough it's not even close you
need to provide evidence that these
fields of study are fundamentally wrong
about everything because that's what you
claim but before you set out to prove
that which I don't think you can I would
ask you to think to think twice because
there are two difficulties that I think
should give us pause before we go around
preaching the young on earth of you
difficulties you know the it theological
difficulty I guess you would say first
of all the argument as I've heard it or
one of the most prominent arguments or
explanations for young earth is that God
made the earth and the universe to look
old and he made I suppose you know and
he put he put fossils in the ground that
look old and he arranged all the
mathematical equations and physics and
everything that they would give us false
information about the world and he
created light beams that were already in
motion on the way to us so as to give
the impression that the stars are much
older than they really are
God by this view is the
thieving us you're saying that God is
playing games he's tricking us rather
than science being a method by which God
reveals more about his own creation
science becomes a method by which God
confounds and confuses and obscures so
apart from how this view degrades
science the bigger issue is how it
degrades God because it gives us a God
who deceives and who doesn't want us to
know things and who tricks us it gives
us this kind of petty pagan God not the
true God not the God of truth not the
God of light not the God who reveals
more and more of himself and this world
to us as we search and explore you know
this gives us a God who wants us to be
in the dark and demands that we never
look outside the pages of the Bible to
learn anything I think that God is much
bigger than bigger than that and much
more honest second point according to
this view modern science isn't just
wrong
it is useless geologists can't tell us
anything about the earth cosmologists
can't tell us anything about the
universe archaeologists can't tell us
anything about the past and if that's
the case then you have set up science
and faith as two competing things you
have taken an adversarial approach to
science and this is a huge stumbling
block for people a serious stumbling
block because when you make someone
choose between science or an ancient
religious texts when you tell them that
only one or the other can be true many
will choose the other if you say to be a
Christian you must reject all of modern
science and if your listener believes
you he is likely to respond well then I
can't be a Christian because
Christianity must just be another
primitive anti science anti knowledge
ignorant superstition like all the rest
but Christianity is not
an ignorant superstition and you don't
need to choose between the two and you
don't need to disbelieve your own eyes
in order to believe the Bible you don't
need to do that
there there there is no reason to set up
this competition between science and the
Bible they can all work together and
much of the time they're doing different
things and they're doing things that are
not in competition the Bible is telling
us why the that is the fundamental
message of the Bible and in science is
telling us you know how and win and to
some extent what this can all work
together so that a person can read the
Bible and be spiritually nourished and
learn quite a bit and then they can go
into science and they can learn even
more about this wonderful creation that
God has given us and and and and even
more than that God reveals himself you
know rather than treating science like
it's some sort of like it's some sort of
you know black magic really we should
see that science is is a form of
Revelation it's God revealing things to
us it's what it means to reveal right
you know we things are being revealed to
us through science about the the nature
of of the earth and how God goes about
creating things and that's a wonderful
thing so
this is a long one that's why I'm not a
young earth creationist and it's why I
think this view
can have the effect of of discrediting
Christianity and and creating very
unnecessary stumbling blocks so I hope
that you'll take that into consideration
thanks for watching thanks for listening
Godspeed